وعلى بعد آلاف الأميال في
موسكو، لا أحد يراقب حرب إسرائيل
ضد حماس عن كثب أكثر من
الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين الذي
يحاول الآن استغلال الحرب ليقول
إنها معركة بين
الولايات المتحدة وإسرائيل ضد بقية العالم.
العالم فريد دبوس في
المقدمة بينما يواصل الجيش الإسرائيلي
حربه ضد
حماس يقوم الزعيم الروسي فلاديمير بوتين
بتأطير الصراع كجزء من
صراع عالمي لأمريكا والغرب ضد
بقية
العالم، إنه النخب الحاكمة الحالية في
الولايات المتحدة وحلفائها.  الأقمار الصناعية
هي المستفيد الرئيسي من
عدم الاستقرار العالمي، فهي تستخرج
منها حصيلة الدماء
بينما أدانت العديد من الدول في جميع أنحاء العالم
حماس بعد الغارة التي وقعت في 7 تشرين الأول/أكتوبر
على جنوب إسرائيل والتي أسفرت عن مقتل أكثر
من 1400 شخص واحتجاز مئات الرهائن بما
في ذلك
الروس، دعت روسيا
وفداً رفيع المستوى من حماس إلى  موسكو تعقد لقاءات مع
زعيم كبير في حماس يقول إن الحركة
ستعطي الأفضلية للأسرى ممن
يسمونهم اقتباسهم من
الأصدقاء الروس. حتى الآن يبدو أنه لم يتم إطلاق سراح أي رهائن روس، ومع ذلك فإن
موسكو لا تنتقد حماس، وبدلاً من ذلك تقوم
فقط بتمزيق إسرائيل من أجل العديد من
الفلسطينيين الذين قتلوا على يد حماس.
في ظل الحملة الجوية المستمرة التي يشنها جيش الدفاع الإسرائيلي في
غزة والتي تدين الإرهاب، فإننا
نختلف بشكل قاطع على أنه
يمكن الرد على الإرهاب من خلال انتهاك
قواعد القانون الإنساني الدولي
بما في ذلك الاستخدام العشوائي للقوة
ضد أهداف من
المعروف أن السكان المدنيين
يتواجدون فيها، ولكن روسيا هي التي شنت لسنوات عديدة
حملة قصف لا هوادة فيها
ضد المناطق التي يسيطر عليها المتمردون المعارضون
للرئيس السوري بشار
الأسد، اتهمت الولايات المتحدة ومختلف
منظمات الإغاثة الدولية موسكو
باستهداف المناطق المدنية عمدا
بما في ذلك المستشفيات والأسواق مما أسفر عن مقتل
وجرح العشرات على الرغم من أن
الكرملين نفى باستمرار هذه
المزاعم والحرب الروسية.  ضد أوكرانيا
تواصل موسكو مرة أخرى إلحاق الضرر
بالمباني المدنية بين عشية وضحاها في مدينة
أوديسا الساحلية،
مما أدى إلى إصابة العديد من الأشخاص فلاديمير بوتين على الرغم من محاولته
القول بأن روسيا تغزو أوكرانيا لمساعدة
الفلسطينيين، فهؤلاء هم جنودنا
وضباطنا واختيار الرجل الحقيقي،
المحارب الحقيقي هو  أن يحمل السلاح
ويقف في الصف مع إخوته ويكون في
مكان يتقرر فيه مصير روسيا والعالم
كله
بما في ذلك مستقبل
الشعب الفلسطيني فلاديمير بوتين هناك
يحاول آرون بشكل أساسي إثارة
بقية العالم بأكمله.  ضد الولايات المتحدة
وحلفائها، بما في ذلك بالطبع
إسرائيل أيضًا، وهذا ليس جديدًا على
فلاديمير بوتين إلى حد كبير منذ أن
غزا أوكرانيا، وكان يتحدث عن
رغبته في نظام عالمي جديد كما قال، نظام تكون فيه
دول مثل الصين وروسيا
أقوى بكثير.  والولايات المتحدة
تضعف هارون